this week
on brian ross investigates the
executioner comes
for the trump five the four men and one
woman
ordered by the justice department to be
executed before president trump leaves
office
next month mr trump's administration has
scheduled more executions for the
transition period
than have ever occurred in the history
of the united states president-elect
biden has vowed to end the death penalty
for federal prisoners
but there are few legal challenges left
for the trump five
two set to be put to death just this
week
this seems like a mad rush to to swing a
wrecking ball
through our justice administration uh
as this administration is on its way out
the door
plus the vaccine countdown with federal
approval expected any day for the kova
19 vaccine
lingering questions about who will get
it and when
and why so many people are already
saying
they don't want it poll after poll shows
up to half of americans surveyed
are hesitant to take the covid vaccine
when it first rolls out
and what about pregnant women what about
children we're joined by dr erwin
redliner
and this week's winners and losers in
the media
see if you agree with what the editors
of mediaite
have to say for the attorney general of
the united states to make that statement
he is either a liar or a fool
or both from the law and crime trial
network
this is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook live
i'm brian ross joined as always by my
colleague rhonda schwartz
and ronnie we're going to get to the
race for the vaccine in just a moment
but first the unseemly race to execute
five prisoners on federal death row set
to be put to death in the waning days
of the trump administration rhonda
that's right and all five of these
executions have been set to be carried
out
before joe biden is sworn in as
president
and during his campaign you'll recall he
expressed his intention to work to end
the federal death penalty
when he was president brighton
since the trump administration
reinstated the death penalty over the
summer
eight federal death throw inmates have
already been executed this year
not since 1889 in the final days of the
grover cleveland presidency
has the united states put to death any
inmate during the transition period
here are the five set to be put to death
before trump leaves office in january
branded bernard this week alfred
bourgeois
this week lisa montgomery january 12th
corey johnson january 14th
dustin higgs january 15th
we're joined now by robert dunham the
executive director of the death penalty
information center and henderson hill
senior counsel at the aclu's capital
punishment project
mr hill let me start with you at this
point is there much that could be done
to stop
any of these executions before donald
trump leaves office well brian
uh my typical response would be there's
an appeal
to mercy there's a appeal to
justice and when you've got
scheduled executions of a young man that
was 18 at the time of the crime
a a young woman who suffered a history
of
sexual abuse that
that makes the knees buffal just
thinking about it
a serious history of serious mental
illness
uh and the doors closed uh i'm not
working with
directly with the defense teams but it's
hard to see the path
uh for clemency or any
any form of mercy to work work its way
through this administration
mr dunham the justice department says is
just carrying out the law
but do you see a race to carry out these
executions
before the end of the trump
administration
i think that's unquestionable what we're
seeing right now is a pattern of conduct
that has no precedent in american
presidential history
and it's out of step uh not just with
presidential history but with the
practices
of the states today mr trump's
administration
has scheduled more executions for the
transition period
than have ever occurred in the history
of the united states you've got to go
back into the 1800s
before you have any administration that
had even more than
one execution during a transition period
and this year we will see fewer
executions
by the states in the united states than
we've seen
in more than 35 years at the same time
we have
a federal administration that is
carrying out a record number
of executions i think what we're seeing
here is
an historical aberration but you don't
see any effort on the part of the
supreme court to step in here do you
want to be
lend a sympathetic year to the people on
death row
well that depends on what the issue is
there have been
there's been ongoing litigation over the
legality of the execution process
and the federal district court has on
numerous occasions declared different
parts of the protocol
the execution plan either illegal or
unconstitutional the united states
supreme court has lifted all stays
vacated all injunctions that relate to
the execution process
so i think it's very unlikely that there
will be a stay of execution
based on the way in which the executions
are to be carried out
that doesn't mean there aren't
substantive issues in the individual
cases
two of the individuals who are scheduled
to be executed corey johnson
and alfred bourgeois have very strong
claims that they're intellectually
disabled
and are not not constitutionally
eligible for execution
there is an avenue potentially for them
based on the fact that the federal death
penalty statute says
you cannot carry out an execution
against somebody who is intellectually
disabled
the supreme court has not yet ruled on
that issue and that gives
some possibility that they could get
relief
mr hill these crimes these men are
convicted of
are particularly brutal and grisly
murders
it's hard to get sympathy for them isn't
it
well uh our nation experiences 14
15 000 murders a year uh each one of
them
are brutal each one of them are
devastating to families and communities
across the country and these
these murders are no less brutal i think
the question
that that we're constantly posed
with the death penalty is whether given
the way
the system of justice works given the
lack of a social
safety net given the tremendous
histories
of sexual abuse uh and childhood trauma
and that many of the folks involved with
these crimes
have experienced and in the folks who
are facing execution
the evidence about these social
histories have not been presented to a
jury
or or considered on the merits by many
of the courts
so the question really becomes whether
or not uh given that situation
uh we're entitled to kill these
these prisoners and uh you know the
observation that a society
level of civilization is judged by how
it treats its prisoners it rings true
here
this seems like a mad rush to to swing a
wrecking ball
through our justice administration
as this administration is on its way out
the door
it's shameful and finally mr hill let me
ask you what would your message be to
the four men
and the one woman on death row uh facing
execution before
uh january 20th
that there are many people in this
country uh
that wish and hope and are working
to avoid this ugly end and that
there are many communities throughout
the country that are affirming their
commitment
to life uh and to appreciate that many
of these folks
have lived real lives of redemption
and we see that we notice that we hear
and see that
uh and across the country there are
states that are moving to
end this this barbaric relic yeah i live
in north carolina
and we haven't had an execution in 14
years we're a slave holding state
formerly louisiana another slave holding
state
hasn't had an execution in 18 years so
we are moving
towards a period of of
of respecting and the value of life
appreciating the
power of redemption and remorse and uh
we hope that the doors open for the
four or five people with these bad
prospects
but they should know uh that there are
people standing
up for them and for the value of life
and we appreciate the acts of remorse
and redemption
henderson hill a senior council of the
acls aclu's
capital punishment project and robert
dunham executive director of the death
penalty information center
thank you both so much for being here
today
thank you brian thank you bro
coming up next the latest on the vaccine
what it means for all of us
what it means for our children you're
watching brian ross investigates on the
law and crime
trial network
for many of us this year has seemed like
we're living in a dickens novel the best
of times the worst of times
a vaccine coming for kova 19 yet daily
record set for the number of deaths in
this country rhonda
that's right brian and charles dickens
also wrote about
the age of foolishness and we certainly
have seen plenty of that as well this
year
indeed well we're now joined by the
perfect antidote for foolishness dr
erwin redliner
an msnbc analyst the founding director
of columbia university's
national center for disaster
preparedness and the author of a new
book
the future of us what children's dreams
mean for
america in the 21st century and dr
ridler thank you so much you are the
gold standard when it comes to what's
really going on
give us a dose of reality given all the
hopes about this vaccine
thanks brian so um you know i've been
the uh sort of classic
uh uh glass half empty person
and i've been looking to make sure that
we're not fooling ourselves about what's
coming and what's not coming
but as far as the vaccines are concerned
brian we have a very very
great opportunity here to start getting
control over this uh
horrendous pandemic which seems to be
getting worse by the day
and the trajectory for going forward is
really not not looking good
but the vaccines offer a tremendous
promise
of having a lot a lot of people become
not susceptible to getting covet there
are many many caveats here and lots of
issues around manufacturing
transporting distributing it and
actually getting into people's arms so
this is not to say it's a magic bullet
that's going to just change everything
tomorrow
but it is offering a lot of hope coming
into the future we have the two
vaccines that are really on the verge of
getting their uh approval from the fda
for this emergency use
authorization they're the uh the pfizer
uh vaccine and the moderna vaccine and
astrozenica's a vaccine that they've
been working on with oxford university
in the uk will also be ready shortly so
there's real
hope here and i think that's important
that said brian if i just may
add that is not going to allow us to
really take our foot off the accelerator
in terms of uh
uh keeping up with the uh
non-pharmaceutical uh
steps and the public health guidelines
like
wearing mass keeping distant being in
well-ventilated rooms
if we have to be in any kind of room
whatsoever but this is all what we're
facing in the future coming up now
and doctor where do you see this country
and this world in terms of cover 19 by
say july 4th by the beginning of summer
well hopefully by july 4th we'll be in a
much better position i
i think we may or may not be able to
celebrate
next year's thanksgiving in november
in a situation that's more uh more
similar more akin to what we've been
used to
doing on thanksgiving which is getting
together with family and friends and
and having a a joyful holiday or joyful
christmas uh
and other winter holidays uh by july
it's really hard to say brian a lot will
depend on how successful we are
in in assuring that all the vaccines
available are in fact safe and that they
work
and they'll be uh able to be distributed
to
be able to get to people and really get
the injection to get the difference
between the vaccine and getting
vaccinated
and that difference uh is significant i
think we'll be able to overcome it but
we have work to do
and doctor a question for you from
miranda schwartz rhonda
hi rhonda in your hello dr redlinger in
your new book you talk about
the dreams of children this is one of
your specialties what
is this pandemic doing to the future of
america's children
what should we do about it yes uh ron
it's a really
good question because i think the impact
of children has not been discussed
enough i don't mean just because of the
disease and children
do get coveted far less frequently than
adults do
but what has happened to them is that
children who are on the margins before
the
pandemic children who are struggling in
school
children need special education children
need just
continuity of education those children
have suffered enormously from the
disruption
in their education and being able to go
to school
and we're going to have a lot to make up
for we can't have these millions of
children
uh fall farther behind than they were
before the pandemic and that's really
what i'm afraid of and i really
it's going to take a lot of effort and
a lot of investment to make sure that
we've helped these kids get back on
track rhonda
is it your position doctor that school
should absolutely stay open
as opposed to bars and restaurants
well a lot of places have done this uh
brian as you're implicating
upside down they've kept bars and
restaurants open and closed schools
i think that's sort of more or less the
opposite of what we should be doing
we should do everything in our power to
make sure that education is available to
kids and they get back in school as
quickly as possible
but to control the community spread we
definitely need to be
still closing the bars and restaurants
and other facilities and gyms and so on
that have become spreader
spreader opportunities children keeping
children in school has
overwhelming necessity for us
and doctor finally you say you're a
glass half empty man do you get
depressed do you get down do you find
you give up hope at some point
i can't brian i have i have uh six
grandchildren
and a big family that we all have to
keep up our spirits and keep uh
getting through this and i think that uh
from a policy point of view i'm always a
little skeptical
from a personal point of view i'm kind
of an angry optimist is how i
characterize myself again we've had a
horrible four years that we're hopefully
uh you know finishing up uh
next few weeks uh with the trump
administration but we're on to bigger
and better things and hopefully
a lot of uh hopefulness uh coming right
up here and i try to stay up
because of my kids and grandchildren
what can i say that's
that's my motivator
well good for you thank you so much dr
urban nothing for joining us from
columbia university
and analyst at msnbc thanks so much for
being here tonight
my pleasure thanks brian
coming up this week's winners and losers
in the media see what the editors
of media had had to say about jack
tapper see if you agree
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media
as chosen by the editors of mediaite and
we're joined by the editor-in-chief of
meteorite aidan mclaughlin meteorite
like the law and crime trial network all
part of the dan abrams
media empire aidan thanks for being here
let's start with the first winner
jake tapper at cnn in this clip showing
off his interviewing skills
president trump has not said if he's
going to attend your inauguration
uh yet do you think it's important that
he's there
you're laughing um i think
it would uh important only in one sense
not in a personal sense important in the
sense that
we are able to demonstrate at the end of
this chaos
that he's created that there is peaceful
transfer of power
with the competing parties standing
there
shaking hands and moving on
and aiden jake gets right to the heart
of it there he's really good at this
isn't he
he really is and you know this was uh a
win
in and of itself because this was the
first sit down that a
journalist television journalist had
with joe biden and kamala harris
the incoming administration uh it was
actually it was a fascinating
interview it stretched the hour uh long
program last weekend
uh sorry last thursday night um and you
know jake pepper has some really
impressive questions uh he kicked off
with a fun one about uh how joe biden
injured his foot uh joe adam had a sort
of interesting story about that
and then moved into more substantive
stuff like the transfer of power between
president donald trump who has still yet
to concede uh the election and joe biden
and then a lot of questions about policy
and what the
biden administration plans to do in
their first 100 days particularly with
the coronavirus
crisis um he also you know pressed the
incoming administration on some of the
criticism that they've faced from right
and left
overall it was a really interesting and
illuminating interview
absolutely and now at the other end of
the spectrum absolutely
lou dobbs at fox business let's take a
look at this clip
to date we have not seen fraud on a
scale he said
that could have affected a different
outcome in the election
for the attorney general of the united
states to make that statement
he is either a liar or a fool
or both he may be perhaps compromised he
may be
simply unprincipled
would it be fair to use the word
unhinged when talking about lou dobbs do
you think aidan
definitely fair to use that word so lou
dobbs is a fox business
host uh who is a intense trump booster
the president watches his show actually
listens to him takes advice from him
um and lou dobbs is one of the more sort
of obsequious of the fox hosts when it
comes to trump
now last week and since the election
he's truly gotten unhinged uh
you saw in that clip there he was
suggesting that because
attorney general william barr has said
that they have yet to find evidence that
there's enough voter fraud to have
stolen the election from donald trump
he's saying that that means that bilbar
must be either compromised or
you know uh sort of have lost his mind
he also suggested
uh that's crazy stuff i mean brian you
know like
bill barr is not compromised he's not a
secret leftist
who's out to destroy uh the trump
administration
um he's just pointing out the obvious
that there's not enough
evidence of fraud that would have swayed
this election from biden who won quite
decisively
to trump um and it wasn't the only thing
that dobbs
said this last week that was pretty nuts
um
he basically spent the whole week uh
drumming up conspiracy theories about
the election being stolen
and mocking uh those who have faced uh
violent threats
um in in order to sort of defend the
election
so in 15 seconds why does fox put up
with it or do they like that
uh they'd catch hell from their
viewership if they let him go and uh he
has good ratings so they might as well
bite their tongues and
keep it going
so he's got a place there on the
schedule as long as he wants it i guess
yeah there's no sign that he's going
anywhere um despite uh
all of the things that he said that fox
executives know is crazy
all right ade mclaughlin editor-in-chief
of media thank you so much for joining
us for this week's
winners and losers and thanks to all of
you for joining us here
and to our great staff at that long
crime for getting us on the air
and off the air
[Music]
you